- Tell everyone what you created and why.
- So, on a recent trip to
a toy store, I saw that
you know, no dolls resembled
my students' hearing devices.
They have hearing aids
and cochlear implants.
So, I went home and
crafted them myself for
to have my students resemble
the toys that they play with.
- That is amazing.
(audience applauding)
Is it so?
You know a lot of people
would just stop right there
and go, "well it just doesn't exist",
but you like went the extra mile.
I know teachers don't have a
lot of spare time in general
- (laughs) Yes.
- My momma was a teacher,
so the fact that you went above.
- Thank you so much
- And beyond, it's amazing.
- I really appreciate that.
- So Genesis had 115 followers
when she posted this tweet
but within 24 hours, the
post had 30,000 retweets
and 150,000 likes.
So Genesis, how did your
students react to the doll?
- They loved them.
Those with cochlear implants reached for
the dolls with cochlear implants
and those with hearing aid reached for
those with hearing aids.
So it really shows how
much they identify with
the toys that they play with.
- Yeah, they got to see.
There was like one of my
favorite parts of being
I got to this film called ugly dolls
and it's like the thing about the dolls
was like everybody kind
of related to one of them
and they weren't your normal doll.
And I though that was brilliant
what you did for them.
- Thank you so much.
- And it's so special.
And are they still playing with the dolls,
how did they react?
- Yes, we have tea
parties, birthday parties.
They make cakes for them.
- [Kelly] That's so good.
- It's so much fun.
They have never been put down since.
- Man, representation is so important
in every facet of what am saying it
for metaphorically everyway.
(audience applauds)
It is so important.
Well, thank you so much.
- Thank you so much.
- I admire your ingenuity and
the passion for your students.
Teachers like you really
do make a difference.
You make kids feels
special and it really does
and can change the
trajectory of their life.
So, thank you so much.
- Thank you for having me.
(audience applauding)
- Well, let's bring up
my first guest girl.
You know her from Glee, Christopher
Guest's brilliant movies
and now from the Marvelous Mrs Maisel
which you can watch on
Amazon prime videos.
So say hello to a woman who has become
a fast friend of the
show, Jane Lynch, y'all.
(audience applauding)
(upbeat music)
You're so fine.
- Good to see you
(audience applaud)
- Come on over.
- I love this set.
- I am so appreciative,
you came back again.
- I did, thank you for inviting me.
- That means you must not have hated it.
- No, I enjoyed it so much.
- Okay, good.
- Yes.
- I was like, that's the goal.
- Well, you're isn't she the best at this?
(audience applauding)
You're so great.
- You're very nice.
You actually, actually, Genesis you are,
are you deaf in your right ear?
- I am, Where is Genesis?
- Yeah, Genesis was just
telling about the dolls.
Are they not kinda cool?
- I just think it's so wonderful.
It's the sweetest thing
I am deaf in my right
ear but one of the things
that I love watching on YouTube
is when they put the cochlear implant
in like a baby for the very first time.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Wow, and they hear their mother's voice
for the very first time.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- That's one of the most
moving things in the world.
- And it's also one of the
things we take advantage of.
Like everybody that has it
and you don't have to
worry that, you know.
- Right, exactly.
- It's like really be grateful.
- Well, I am really grateful too.
I have one ear and it's bionic.
It's so not gonna wanna--
- It's stepped up to the play.
- It has totally made up for
the one that doesn't work so.
And it's been all my life so I didn't have
to have like that adjustment period.
- Yeah, and music is important to you.
- It is.
- I know, So like what if I,
if you were to tell me
like what's the song
you've played like the most right now?
- Probably Elton John, "Someone
Saved My Life Tonight".
- [Kelly] Oh!
- I mean I rock out on that one.
- Great song.
- It's great, isn't it?
- Yeah.
- It's like 4 songs in one.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It goes all over the place.
It's like an epic poem.
- Yeah.
- I love it
- [Kelly] That's amazing.
- You all know that song?
- Its so amazing.
- Well, maybe people who are like age.
But even the youngsters
know it too, right?
- Yeah. It's Elton's freaking John.
- Elton freaking John,
who won a damn Oscar.